-Josh, welcome back.
It is always great to see you.
You know I love
when you come on.
-It's good to be here.
-How's the kids?
How's the family?
-There's so many things
that they're into.
My daughter's 3 1/2,
my son's 7 1/2.
So he's very much into Minecraft
and you know...
Pokémon, I'm sure, right?
I hear the moans.
-You hear the -- Yeah.
-No, and I was telling someone
the other day,
I was saying, you know,
some of the best acting
I've ever done in my life --
I mean, I'm talking
about Academy Award style --
-Yeah.
-...is pretending to my son
that I understand
what Pokémon is about.
[ Laughter ]
No, I'm serious.
Like, we have conversations
about it, and I'm like,
"Really?"
[ Laughter ]
"So that thing -- and how many
points is that one worth?
Oh, okay, cool."
By the way, I mean,
I can say this 'cause he's not
going to see the show --
I don't think he knows
what the hell it's about either.
-No, no one knows about points.
I didn't know you get points.
-His whole thing is always like,
"Oh, that's a fake card."
I'm like, "They're really in."
He's like, "No." I'm like,
"How can you tell it's a fake?"
He's like, "Dude, you rip it,
and, like, you can tell,
like, the paper."
I'm like, "I didn't buy you
a fake card.
Where did you get
a fake card from?"
-I wanted you to come on,
I wanted you to bring
a Baltimore thing.
-Yeah.
-Like a snack or something.
-Of course.
-You brought me
something here tonight,
which I'm very excited...
because I want to talk
about your new series,
but you brought me
a snowball maker.
-Yes. This is why --
Well, you know, you were asking
to bring something
from Baltimore.
And if I think about something
that is uniquely Baltimore,
it's a snowball.
-Okay.
-Similar to an Italian ice,
a little more granular.
And, you know,
so I brought some...
This is my
Little Snowie machine.
My Little Snowie Max.
-This is from your house?
-This is from my house.
My dad had one.
And when I was in Baltimore,
I was like, I think I had like
six snowballs one night.
I was like,
"I think I need to get
one of these for my apartment."
So I have one.
-This was before you had kids?
-This is --
No, this is yesterday.
[ Laughter ]
And these are flavors
from a place in Baltimore
called Kavern Syrups,
and it's important.
The syrups are very important
because you can't have
any of that high-fructose
corn syrup crap.
You know, these are
just pure 100% sugar
to pump into your --
to pump into your veins.
-Okay. That quality sugar.
-Just 100% sugar.
-But Kavern is the way to go
if you're going to get syrup.
Kavern Syrups in Baltimore,
Maryland, is a great place.
-Okay.
How do we do it?
-So, let me do it.
Let me make you some snowballs.
-I appreciate this.
-First, I'm gonna tell you,
this is very loud.
So I don't know if the guys
want to, you know...
-No, they don't want to do...
-Well, I mean, you know.
-Let's talk about your -- I want
to talk about your show,
"We Own This City."
-Yeah.
Well, it is based
in Baltimore, unlike...
[ Machine whirs ]
-What? What?!
-Yeah, well...
-[ Indistinct ]
-Where is it set?
-Takes place in Baltimore!
-Set in Baltimore?!
-Yeah, it's great!
[ Whirring continues ]
[ Whirring stops ]
-Kids hear this sound,
they come running.
Don't put your fingers
in there, Josh!
-Dude, you just gave kids
SpaghettiOs on a damn hot dog.
[ Laughter ]
Gonna worry about my fingers
in your snowball?
Get out of here, Fallon!
Alright.
-Okay.
-Which flavor?
Now, here I have cherry.
I have Skylite, which was mine
as a kid growing up.
And basically,
I just call it blue.
I couldn't tell you what flavor.
-Blue is the flavor.
-Spearmint for -- you know,
maybe for your parents.
And this is an egg custard,
right?
This is one of the...
[ Audience oohs ]
Thank you.
This is one of the most unique,
original -- one of the first
flavors, I think.
It was made originally with eggs
and vanilla and sugar and syrup.
And this is a classic
Baltimore flavor.
I would suggest you try this.
-Let's go with cherry.
-Is that alright? Alright.
[ Laughter ]
Let's start with cherry, then --
-You would pick cherry.
-We'll work our way
to the egg custard!
-You would pick cherry.
Really?
-Egg custard is what you want?!
-What do you want to go with?
-You want to have a hot dog off?
-Yeah, let's go, right now!
-Bring your egg custard
on the hot dog!
-Let's go!
Do you want cherry
or you want egg custard?
-Alright, give me egg custard.
Yeah.
I'll make you one.
-Alright, you make me one.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Ooh. Oh, I'm screwing it up.
There you go.
-Oh, I see.
It's seeping right in there.
-Yeah, you get it
all up in there.
-Let me try this.
-Alright, now. Here you go.
That's yours.
-Bottoms up.
-What the hell did you do?
-It's like a mint julep.
Like a mint julep, like...
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's the best.
-That's what I'm telling you.
-That is the best.
It's like a cream soda.
I love it.
-Give me the damn thing.
-Alright.
Um, Josh...
Tell me about your show, please.
Who do you play?
This is a true story.
-It's based on a true story.
Justin Fenton, an incredible
reporter in Baltimore,
used to be
with The Baltimore Sun.
Now he's with
the Baltimore Banner.
I had followed his reporting
very closely.
It's a true story about
the Gun Trace Task Force
and corruption
in Baltimore Police Department.
And David Simon
and George Pelecanos,
you know, created "The Wire."
-"The Wire," not too shabby.
-This is their world,
and they know it well.
[ Applause ]
Yes. Thank you.
And, you know,
unlike a snowball,
it's not the most pleasant story
about Baltimore,
but one that's important
to be told.
And yeah, it's all real,
and it really happened.
-I always love when you come on,
and congrats,
you're fantastic in this.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Josh Charles
in "We Own This City."
Take a look.
-I could use your insight.
-Yeah? About what?
-Well, you have an impressive
number of complaints with IAD.
46, by my count.
-Only one sustained.
-But given the number --
-Ma'am.
You know what the Baltimore cops
who don't have complaints
are doing every day?
-No.
-They sure as hell
ain't policing.
-Mm.
-'Cause if you want
to do this job,
then you're gonna get complaints
for doing this job.
-So what you're saying --
-I'm saying the reason
so many complaints
are unsustained
is 'cause they're coming
from criminals
who are being policed
for doing crime.
And that's all I have to say.
-Oh! Josh Charles!
Check out the finale
of "We Own This City"
Monday on HBO.
We love you, Josh Charles.